the coronavirus was declared a pandemic
on Wednesday pandemics are by definition
contagious diseases that spread
worldwide kovat 19 is one of two current
pandemics the other being hiv/aids
there's been Spanish flu smallpox typhus
tuberculosis and much more
every pandemic is difference every one
frightening and managed in a different
way the scientific criteria for an
influenza pandemic have been met the
most recent pandemic before this was the
2009 flu called
h1n1 or swine flu further spread is
considered inevitable as many of us
remember it led to a chaotic scramble to
vaccinate the most vulnerable those over
the age of 65 under the age of 5 and
pregnant women I don't want anybody to
be alarmed but I do want everybody to be
prepared before a tapered off in the
spring of 2010 h1n1 infected between 10
and 20% of the world's population and
killed up to five hundred and seventy
five thousand a decade before h1n1 the
World Health Organization issued its
first pandemic plans in 1999 that was
five years after Richard Preston's
chilling international bestseller the
hot zone which detailed the origins of
two terrifying Central African diseases
including Ebola hundreds more infected
and it's spreading like a brush fire the
movie outbreak in 1995 imagine an Ebola
like outbreak in California
more recently contagion in 2011 examined
the breakdown of social order during an
outbreak so we had a virus
treatment protocol and no vaccine of
this tongue hollywood often deals in
fast-moving fiction but the world has
seen slower more sustained spreads the
most devastating pandemic in history was
the black death between 1347 and 1351
the bubonic plague killed up to 200
million including between thirty and
sixty percent of Europe's population
later smallpox was responsible for
hundreds of thousands of deaths a year
peaking in the 18th century it remains
the only infectious disease that's been
completely eradicated cholera became
widespread in the 19th century and
remains a major problem in areas without
a clean water supply the worst pandemic
of the 20th century was the Spanish flu
the original outbreak involving h1n1 it
killed up to 100 million 1/4 of the
world's population has been infected
with tuberculosis malaria is always a
threat in tropical regions neither
though were currently considered
pandemics the only other disease
classified as such today is hiv/aids
first identified by the CDC in 1981
because of the HIV virus that I have
attained I will have to retire from the
Lakers but it was this announcement from
NBA legend Magic Johnson in 1991 that
helped the world realize hiv/aids could
affect anyone I plan on going on living
for a long time
you guys always have while treatments
have improved dramatically the disease
has killed more than 32 million over the
past three decades and we all remember
that long right you and we forget these
past 30 years I think we also forget the
fear that originally was there but I'm
so uncertain as to how you would acquire
the disease we know now we didn't then
right as they say nothing spreads like
fear right right research not history
information that's real